with two weeks gone now and the brady
decision settled a bit can we clearly
say that robert kraft chose bill
belichick over tom brady
yes i mean we can yeah i think we could
say that you know i you know i think
it's a deeper conversation than that but
i think ultimately yes i mean this is
bill belichick
he's uh he's the best coach in the
history of football there's no doubt
about that and even though we know tom
brady's in that conversation for best
player best quarterback in the history
of football you know it doesn't matter
he's still 43 here at the start of this
next season and
it's coming to an end and the patriots
are the patriots because they've made
these tough hard-line decisions
throughout their history and yeah i
think you know mr kraft finally came to
the point we said okay the guy's getting
really up there in age it is coming to
an end and i'm gonna go with the guy
who's built this empire and let him
continue his vision here for the future
yeah look i i think the bottom line is
this there was only a limited amount of
time that
we were going to continue to see
tom brady with the patriots bill
belichick was always going to
be there longer and yeah why are you
gonna choose
why are you gonna force belichick to
take a guy he doesn't want maybe piss
belichick off he's the guy who's gonna
be there he's the guy who inevitably was
going to be trying to build another
super bowl team without tom brady it was
a no-brainer and look that's the way you
own a team you don't meddle you step
aside and you let your football people
make the decisions especially when they
have six pelts on the wall and or
pellets on the horse you let belichick
call what he wants who he wants how he
wants and you don't get in the way of
that
no i totally agree i mean he is the
architect yeah players get old it just
comes to an end at some point you know
coaches can still be really good coaches
in their late 60s and be top of the line
there that way so you know again it's
going to be some take some adjusting but
the patriots you know am i sitting
you're going to go they're going to the
super bowl i'm not ready to say that but
if anybody thinks the patriots are going
to fall off a cliff and be irrelevant
this year i think that's crazy it was
the number one defense in football last
year they won most games last year
through their defense
so you know to think that they can't
play that style of football once again
yeah as jared stood him as clutch or as
knowledgeable as tom brady no he's not
but don't manage him the right way to
where they're still going to be a big
pain in the ass for everybody in the afc
yeah i agree with you completely and i
think the idea that the expectations are
reduced i think that makes things even
more interesting for the patriots
because
it will feel like even if they get to
the playoffs it will feel like a very
good year for the for the new england
patriots and who knows maybe they'll be
there right in the thick of things again
like they always seem to
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports